welcome
to the first plenary talk of the 2020
virtual brain initiative
investigators meeting i'm joshua gordon
director of the nimh
and i'm really pleased to be here with
you all virtually
especially because it means i don't have
to wear this mask
which hopefully you will all recognize
as
a picture of the surface of the brain
akin to cutting-edge innovations of the
brain initiative we hope
that you will be engaged and inspired by
this novel virtual meeting environment
um as you probably have already seen
from navigating to
this plenary we're
really excited to have a
meeting that we think will be creative
that will enable you to hear the latest
but also
to interact with everyone in fact
there's a lot for you to explore on this
website
uh beyond just the talks and the
symposia
um when you first logged in you should
have seen a welcome video
by the director of the nih brain
initiative dr john nye i should say the
new director welcome john
um there's also a video at the brain
initiative booth where
the nih director francis collins
interviews dr nye about the initiative
and and where it might
go there's lots of other organizations
with booths there's tons of information
there's also lots of ways to engage with
each other throughout the meeting
via the virtual poster hall with over
400 posters
numerous chat rooms a networking lounge
and
uh and we do encourage people to use
social media be sure to use the hashtag
studybrain that's lowercase study
uppercase brain
on social media to document the virtual
conference experience as much as
possible
immediately after this talk we're going
to engage in a q a session with the
speaker
just as if it were live but there's an
added bonus to being able to
interact in the virtual space besides
not having to wear masks
you'll also be able to post your
questions at any time through the talk
so anytime a question occurs to you go
ahead and use the q
a box which should be i believe on the
lower left of your screen
and we'll select from amongst those
questions
which ones the speaker will answer i'm
going to ask those questions for you
but please populate that q a box at any
time throughout the talk
and we will prioritize them and get to
them at the end
for now though um besides welcoming you
to the meeting and welcoming to this
talk i want to introduce our first
plenary speaker
dr rachel wilson the martin family
professor of basic research in the field
of neurobiology
at harvard medical school dr wilson
completed her post-doctoral training at
the california institute of technology
before joining the faculty
in the department of neurobiology at
harvard in 2004
an investigator at the howard hughes
medical institute she is also a member
of the national academy of sciences a
macarthur foundation fellow
and the first blavatnik national
laureate in life sciences
dr wilson studies the neural mechanisms
of sensory motor
integration and navigation in drosophila
her lab
works to understand how descending
signals from the brain control
navigation paths
how spatial maps are integrated with
internal goals to produce locomotor
commands
how spatial maps reorganize around a new
environment and how map-guided
navigation is seemingly
seamlessly integrated with other
navigational strategies
i think her work is creative outstanding
impactful
and today i'm really looking forward to
hearing from her
about the neural mechanisms of
navigation behavior
so now sit back and enjoy uh dr wilson's
talk and remember to
type in your questions in the q a box
thank you for that kind introduction and
it's a real pleasure to have the
opportunity to speak today
at the sixth annual nih brain initiative
meeting
what i'm going to talk to you about
today are the neural mechanisms of
navigation behavior
we study navigation in drosophila partly
because
i think the fly is arguably the most
tractable
organism in terms of neuroscience around
today
that's partly because the fly brain is
relatively
small and simple and what that means is
that also by now we have
a full serial section electron
microscopy data set
comprising the entire female fly brain
and that means anyone in the world
can investigate the connectivity of the
neurons that they care about
and this has been really helpful in
allowing us to formulate hypotheses
about interesting computations
in many of those computations occur in
the context of navigation
now flies perform a lot of interesting
navigation behaviors
one of the simplest is something that we
might call compass behavior
the aim of compass behavior is just to
travel in a straight line
because that's the fastest and most
efficient way to get anywhere
now of course human subjects tend to
circle when they're blindfolded we're
unable to walk in a straight line
without
some type of feedback from the
environment and that's because our
bodies are asymmetric and our brains are
asymmetric
and the same is true of other animals so
many animals travel in a straight line
by referencing some visual cue in the
environment which is often the sun
and by fixing a particular angle
relative to the sun
they're able to achieve a straight-line
path by keeping
the sun at that fixed angle relative to
their body
so i know something about how compass
behavior is implemented we know that it
requires
neurons in this doughnut-shaped
structure near the center of the brain
in this image
and the core components of this
structure are neurons that
we often call compass neurons or epg
neurons
and so these neurons form a topographic
map of heading direction here the arrows
represent the preferred heading
of each neuron in the array and
that means that there's a kind of a bump
of activity in the array at any given
time
which rotates as the fly turns
and so we know that this structure
receives
visual input input informing
the compass about the position of a
visual cue and that allows the compass
to update
its estimate of the fly's current
heading
and then we know from behavioral data
that that
current heading estimate must be
compared with some internally stored
goal
and when the current estimated heading
doesn't match
the goal heading that generates a
steering command that adjusts the
heading and also adjusts the position of
the visual cue on the retina
we also know that this compass functions
in the dark
and that means that the compass the
heading estimate
must receive input from either
proprioceptors in the limbs that
indicate that steering maneuvers are
occurring
and or copies of steering commands motor
reference copy cues
what i'm going to tell you about today
are three stories first
i'll tell you that visual inputs to
compass neurons can change with
experience
second i'll show you that compass
neurons integrate spatial cues from
multiple sensory modalities
and finally i'll show you the compass
output acts in parallel with stimulus
directed pathways
to control steering so this first
project
was spearheaded by ivette fisher with
help from jenny lou
and isabel d'alessandro
now epg neurons receive their visual
inputs from
neurons that we call r neurons they're
sometimes also called ring neurons
because the axon of each r neuron or
ring neuron
forms a ring that circles around the
entire compass array
and it forms anatomical connections with
every epg neuron
now there are many r neurons each with
distinct visual receptive field
locations
and they each wrap around the compass so
we can think of them
if we sort of unwrap the circle as
forming an
all to all matrix of r neuron to epg
neuron anatomical connections
and i mentioned that these are neurons
have spatially selective visual septic
fields we can
show this by making an in vivo whole
cell patch clip recording from one of
these neurons
as the fly is presented with for example
a bright
vertical bar which is randomly flash at
different locations
and by reverse correlation analysis we
see that this neuron responds only when
the visual object is presented at a
particular
horizontal location and this result
really just
confirms and extends what is previously
should have been shown by the vector
ramen's lab using calcium imaging to
study
the visual receptive fields of our
neurons
now i told you that our neurons form all
to all anatomical connections with epg
neurons
but we wondered whether the functional
connectivity might be more
patchy or selective than that but
because if functional connections were
all equivalent
then the compass would essentially be
throwing away the spatial information
that the r neuron population contains
so to test whether that was true we want
to design an experiment to measure the
visual receptive field of epg neurons
we know that our neurons are gabaergic
so we expect
the visual responses of epg neurons to
be inhibitory
and calcium imaging is not a great way
to study that
so we again turn to in vivo wholesale
passionate recordings to study visually
evoke synaptic input to epg neurons
so this sort of shows you the
experimental setup
again we're flashing a bright vertical
bar randomly around
the screen and this shows you
the responses of a particular neuron to
three presentations um here shown in
different colors
of a visual stimulus 90 degrees to the
left
versus 90 degrees to the right what
you'll notice is that this neuron is
reliably inhibited by the first location
and it's not responding to the second
location and these are bona fide visual
responses because they don't correlate
with the animal's yaw velocity its
rotational velocity
on any given trial in fact in these
experiments the
animals made no systematic move toward
or away from the visual stimulus maybe
because it was flashed randomly and
briefly around the screen
so these are sample trials for one
neuron here's data from all 73 epg
drones we were quoted from in 68 flies
and we've organized these cells
according to their receptive field
location you'll notice that every cell
is inhibited
by visual stimuli in a particular
location but it's not inhibited by
visual stimuli in other locations
indicating that the functional map from
our neurons to epg neurons is not all at
all
collectively these neurons tile visual
space as one might expect
you'll notice that some neurons are
actually excited by visual stimuli that
don't inhibit them
and we think that represents
disinhibition because we know from
other published work from vivek
jayaraman's lab there's sort of a
functional
altol inhibition among epg neurons so if
one epg neuron is inhibited the others
are disinhibited
now we wanted to know how do these
visual receptive fields
compare to the heading tuning of these
same cells
so in addition to mapping the cell's
visual receptor field by flashing
the vertical bar around the screen
randomly we also allow the animal to
walk
for a period of minutes in a virtual
reality environment
where the animal could control the
position of the ball bar
by turning on the spherical treadmill
and what we found in most neurons is
that the visual receptive field
was quite congruent with the cell's
heading tuning
in a virtual reality in a few cells
the visual receptor field didn't match
the heading tuning very well
and that's interesting because these are
cells where the visual receptive field
might be
relatively poorly aligned with the
proprioceptive input
or steering command input to the compass
so just to summarize the data i just
showed you suggests that the pattern of
functional connectivity is
patchy in a few
[Music]
flies were able to record sequentially
from two adjacent epg neurons and we
found that they always had adjacent
visual receptive fields
and so that suggests that the retina
topic map
of space represented by the r neuron
ensemble and purple
is sort of mapped in a systematic and
quasi-linear manner
onto the circular array of epg neurons
so what is that all matrix anatomical
connections for
we wondered whether it might represent a
sort of a
matrix of potential synaptic connections
that could be
formed or weakened as a result of visual
motor experience
so to test that was whether that was
true we designed an experiment to change
the fly's visual motor experience
in the middle of the experiment and we
started to look at that using calcium
imaging
so we express gcamp and all the epg
neurons we image the entire array as the
fly walks on a spherical treadmill
in virtual reality with a single bright
object
we sort of unrolled the circular array
of compass neurons
so different wedges of the compass are
on the y-axis
and times on the x-axis and you can see
the bump of activity here
shown as a dark patch moving around the
compass as the fly turns
we can decode the direction that the fly
seems to think it's pointed in
based on these epg neurons i'm showing
you that in green
here and i'm overlaying that with the
fly's actual heading in virtual reality
in magenta
and both those data sets are double
plotted here on the vertical axis so you
can see them wrap around continuously as
the fly turns 360 degrees
you can see they agree with each other
which just means the compass is working
accurately under these conditions
then in the middle of the experiment we
allow a second object to appear
which is directly opposite the first
object we call this the training period
what we see um here is that the fly
often seems to become confused about the
direction that it's facing in
and we think that because the bump
occasionally jumps all the way across
the circle
to inhabit a location about 180 degrees
away
you'll notice toward the end of this
second to two minute snippet of data the
fly makes a full
360 degree turn around the arena
and you can see during that period of
time instead of flowing all the way
around the circle
the bump activity actually flows twice
around half the circle
and that just means that sort of halfway
through that turn
the coordinate frame of the compass
jumped by 180 degrees
you can see that more clearly by looking
at the offset the difference between the
decoded heading the actual heading
which is consistent during pre-training
but toggles between two values
during training now this is all kind of
what we would expect
the interesting thing for us the
question we wanted to ask is
was there a persistent effect of this
training experience after training
so we ended every experiment by
returning to a virtual reality
environment with one object
this is the same environment as during
the pre-training period
what we found here though is that the
offset of the compass continued to
toggle
between two values about 180 degrees
apart
as if the experience of the ambiguous
scene had imprinted itself
on the compass we saw some change in the
offset in about half of our experiments
and in all of those experience
experiments the offset
tended to um settle down to one of two
values either the old value or the new
value
within a few minutes so the question
that we wanted to ask was
does this training experience change the
visual receptive fields
of epg neurons to test that we returned
to wholesale patchline recording
during the pre-training period a typical
neuron was fairly well tuned to heading
as shown here
that again just summarizes the neurons
tuning profile in virtual reality with
one object
and then after pre-training we rapidly
map the cell's visual receptive field
using a bright bar flashed around the
arena as before
and as before we saw that the visual
receptive field was typically congruent
with the cell's heading tuning
now during the training period we see
that this cell acquires actually
two preferred heading directions
and that actually makes sense given what
we saw during the calcium imaging recall
that the bump would sometimes
um jump 180 degrees across the circle
so we would expect each epg cell to
acquire
two different heading tuning profiles
the question we wanted to answer is what
happens to the cell's visual receptive
field
map after the training experience
so to assess that after training we
again
flash the bright bar around the arena to
measure the cell's response to each
receptive field location
um and again just keep in mind that
during this
there's only one bar visible at any
given time
what we see is that the cell's visual
receptor field is perturbed
after training we saw this in a
significant fraction of our experiments
and we found that the perturbation
in the cell's visual receptive field
tended to be larger
for cells that were had a larger
heading tuning that were more strongly
tuned to heading during the training
experience
so what that suggests is that visual
receptive fields are remodeled during
training
and this remodeling of plasticity
requires not only visual experience
but it also requires the bump to be
actively embodied
actively dwelling on the cell in
question
so to summarize our results in a model
we think that during
pre-training there's a systematic
mapping from
our neurons onto epg neurons so that
if any r neuron is activated by a visual
cue it sends the bump effectivity to the
epg neurons where it makes the weakest
synaptic connections
because these synaptic connections are
inhibitory
and we think that this training
experience with this particular
vr environment that's so ambiguous
essentially doubles the spatial
frequency of the synaptic weight matrix
from our neurons onto epg neurons
and we think that that is a likely
outcome
if one imagines that the learning rule
at these synaptic connections is
associative ltd
such that the gabaergic synapse from our
neurons onto epg neurons
is weakened when the r neuron is
co-activated with the epg neuron
now when an r neuron is activated it
should
activate with roughly equal probability
two
widely separated epg neurons and if
there's
all to all inhibition among epg neurons
the result is that the bump
toggles between two offsets about 180
degrees apart
so what i've shown you then is that each
compass neuron has a spatially specific
visual receptive field
experience can change the visual
receptive fields of compass neurons
and this process reorients the compass
relative to the world
i should mention that this work was
published recently
back to back with a companion paper from
the vector ramen's lab
that has a more theoretical focus
so in the second part of my talk i'll
show you that compass neurons integrate
spatial cues from multiple sensory
modalities
and this work was led by tatsu okubo who
had help from paula patella
and isabelle d'alessandro
so i need you to know that compass cues
can actually be multimodal
i've talked to you about visual cues as
compass cues the sun is the best known
example of this but there's evidence
that
animals can use other kinds of
environmental cues as compass cues
during compass behavior
and wind is an interesting example of
this
so there are reports that animals can
walk in straight lines
in a wind environment that is in a
steady wind
in a direction that's not necessarily
upwind or downwind
and we know that they're using the wind
direction for navigation
because if we rotate the wind or rotate
the animal relative to the wind
the animal makes a compensatory turn to
now regain its original heading
direction
relative to the wind vector so this
suggested to us that perhaps wind would
have an effect on compass neurons
analogous to the effect of a sun-like
visual cue
on compass neurons so to test this
prediction we express gcamp and epg
neurons
we image the epg array while presenting
wind from many directions around the fly
we actually in these experiments
presented wind randomly from different
directions
rapidly interleaved and what we found is
that
as the wind direction jumped the bump
would also jump
and in most flies like these the
relationship between wind direction and
bump location is fairly smooth
continuous and linear you'll notice
again that i'm double
plotting each data point on the y-axis
so you can see this line form
continuously as we wrap around
the 360 degree circle notice
interestingly that the offset between
wind direction and bump location is
different than different flies
and this is reminiscent of observations
that have been made many times
noting that the offset between
the bump location and a visual cue is
also
different in different flies and it
suggests to us
that there may be some plasticity in the
mapping from wind
to compass coordinates just as we now
know there is
experience dependent plasticity in the
mapping from visual cues to compass
coordinates
now i've been telling you about r
neurons and how they can send visual
signals to epg neurons the r neurons
i've been focusing on
implicitly here are just actually a
subset of our neurons
they're the most well characterized r
neurons and they receive synaptic input
from a particular visual brain region
but there are other less well
characterized r neurons we might call
them
atypical r neurons and they receive
synaptic input
from a different brain region called the
lateral accessory lobe
and we wondered whether these atypical r
neurons might be sensitive to wind
direction
whether they might form a continuous
topographic map of wind direction
and whether they might be responsible
for the effect of wind on the compass
so to test this we hyper polarize these
atypical r neurons these green r neurons
by over expressing the inwardly
rectifying potassium channel k
r 2.1 and just to summarize those
results
i'll tell you that k our overexpression
we found interferes with the effect of
wind on the compass quite significantly
by contrast kr 2.1 over
expression in these visual r neurons
interferes with the effect of visual
stimuli on the compass
but it doesn't interfect with interfere
with the effect of wind on the compass
so this motivated us to go in and make
in vivo wholesale paschal recordings
from these green r neurons the atypical
r neurons for the cognition d i'll just
say that these are the r1
class of our neurons we found indeed
that they responded to wind in a manner
that's dependent on wind direction
so in this example cell you'll see the
cell is excited by
wind from the contralateral direction
it's inhibited by headwind
and more strongly inhibited by wind from
the ipsilateral direction
so you might be wondering how do these r
neurons get information about
wind direction so i want to step back
for a moment and think about
the mechanics of wind sensing in
peripheral organs
so it's already known that drosophila
sends wing direction
largely through their antennae and
actually the largest
peripheral mechanosensory organ in the
fly resides in the antenna there are
almost 500 neurons in each antenna
devoted to encoding
the position of the antenna and the
antenna
are passively displaced in response to
wind
and wind from different directions
produces different antenna displacements
here i'm showing you video stills from
videos that we took of the antenna
viewed from above the fly as we
presented the wind from different
directions
in black you can see the silhouette of
the antenna and the head
at rest when no wind is present
in a magenta you can see the new
positions of the antenna
when wind is presented from each of
these different example directions
so we measured internal displacements in
response to wind from many directions
i'm here i'm plotting displacement on
the y-axis and wind direction on the
x-axis for both the left and the right
antenna
and we did this for four different air
speeds
and what you'll see is that at
for any given air speed it's really not
possible to
determine the direction of the wind by
looking at one antenna alone
but if you integrate input from each
antenna it turns out that you can
deduce with reasonable accuracy the
direction of the wind invariant to wind
speed
and so we might expect that if our
neurons are truly encoding
wind direction and variant in speed wind
speed they would
receive input from both antenna
and in fact we did find clear evidence
of bilateral integration in our neurons
so we made again wholesale hatchling
recordings from
these atypical r neurons these r1
neurons
and we then made displaced we made
control the displacements of the antenna
both antennae independently using a pair
of
highly precise piezoelectric devices
so when we displaced the ipsilateral
antenna
um you can see in cell one at the top
the cell is excited its firing rate
increases above baseline in response to
moving the ipsilateral antenna toward
the head
and its firing rate decreases below
baseline below that black line
when the ipsilateral antenna is moved
away from the head
and the reverse is true for the
contralateral antenna indicating that
this cell
integrates antagonistic input from the
two antenna
the same is true of cell two except here
in cell two the contribution
of the contralateral antenna is larger
relative to the contribution of the
ipsilateral antenna
and it turns out then if we um study
bilateral displacements
the two antenna that um represent the
displacements that
occur in response to wind from different
directions
we see that both cells are tuned to wind
direction
they have different wind tuning
preferences because the relative
contribution of the different antenna
is different i should point out that
both cells are recorded on the same side
of the brain in the same brain
hemisphere
so this indicates again diversity across
our neurons within the same brain
hemisphere in their preferred wind
direction
and interestingly for both cells the
shape of the wind direction tuning curve
is relatively invariant to wind speed
which we can understand as being the
consequence
of integrating antagonistic input from
the 2 and 10
so we measured internal displacements in
response to a wide variety of wind
directions
shown here on the left for the left
antenna and the right antenna
and i just want you to look at that in
comparison with the shapes of the tuning
curves of our neurons
shown here in the center column these
are neuron tuning curves were actually
all recorded simultaneously
in g-cam imaging from
our neuron cell bodies and as it happens
they all reside in the same brain
hemisphere of the same fly
note the diversity in their preferred
wind directions
and interestingly we can sort of account
for the shapes of these tuning curves
by simply taking the displacement of the
left antenna
and subtracting the displacement of the
right antenna
after scaling the two displacement
curves
by the scaling factors alpha and beta
which are the only free variables
in the model what you'll notice is that
this model
provides quite a good fit to these are
neuron tuning curves
and what that argues is that these sort
of sharp discontinuities in the tuning
curve of each r neuron
reflect the mechanical discontinuities
in the antenna mechanics as a response
to wind turning around the fly
interestingly these sharp
discontinuities are not so present when
we look
at the epg neural ensemble rather
when we look at ep general wind tuning
curves we see that
all wind directions are treated more or
less equally by the ensemble
suggesting that the constraints imposed
by
peripheral mechanics in the
mechanosensory organ have been mitigated
at the level of the transformation from
r neurons to epg neurons
and i'll just summarize a lot of data
here by telling you that
we discovered that our neurons are just
three synapses downstream from
mechanoreceptors and johnson's organ
and they're directly post-synaptic to a
cell type called wll
which forms um the most important single
synaptic input
to most r1 neurons and
each r neuron integrates gabaergic
inhibition
from wll neurons contralaterally
with excitation from our neurons
ipsilaterally which is conveyed through
gap junctions or electrical synapses and
thus
in in this manner our neurons are able
to integrate input
from the right and left antenna so thus
the blue neurons in this diagram
essentially encode unilateral and
teneral displacement
but because of this bilateral
integration our neurons can encode
wind direction per se and then
epg neurons because they combine input
from wind sensitive r neurons and
visual r neurons as well as other
sources of input indicating
self-motion cues epg neurons can
therefore encode a more
abstract and general quantity which is
heading direction
so our sort of picture model looks like
this
we conjecture that um
the wind direction our neurons in green
and the visual cue position are neurons
in purple
that are co-activated by the same
sort of view of the environment these
neurons will form
similar patterns of synaptic weights
onto epg neurons
so that if they are co-activated they
cooperate
in sending the bump of activity to the
appropriate location in the compass
and if the sun disappears behind a cloud
for example or the sun goes down
then wind alone could function to send
the bump
to the right location although possibly
with lower accuracy
of course the relationship between the
wind direction and
the horizontal angle of the sun is not a
fixed one in the environment
and so this raises the um possibility
that
the synaptic weight matrix for one or
both types of r neurons
would have to be remodeled again and
again throughout the day
in order to form um a self-consistent
functional map of the environment onto
the compass
and we're interested in testing these
hypotheses in the future
so to summarize i've shown you that the
compass tracks the direction
of the wind and specialized our neurons
combine mechanosensory signals from both
antennae
to represent wind direction in an
intensity and variant manner
and finally i've shown you the
transformation from r neurons to epg
neurons
eliminates the coding biases imposed by
peripheral mechanics
and integrates wind direction signals
with visual signals in a common circular
coordinate frame
so finally i'll show you that compass
output acts in parallel with stimulus
directed pathways to control steering
and this work was spearheaded by sasha
ray shubski who had help from stephen
holtz
isabel d'alessandro anna lee quinn
vanderbeck
isabel haber and peter gibb
so this work began with an interest that
we had
in descending neurons descending neurons
by definition have dendrites and cell
bodies in the brain
and then they send their axons down to
the ventral nerve cord
which is sort of the insect analog of
the spinal cord and vertebrates
and we've got interested in one
particular type of descending neuron
called a2 descending neurons
because each of these neurons sends an
axonal projection
down to target
all of the ipsilateral leg control
regions of the ventral cord
and we know this based on beautiful
anatomical work published
recently from gwyneth cards lab
and gwynslep also at the same time
generated
a large collection of split golf 4 lines
that allowed us to target these cells
for observation and manipulation which
was essential to the study
we're also interested in this cell
because an anatomically similar
cell type turns out to be correlated
with steering maneuvers and crickets
so we wondered whether the same might be
true of this cell
so we again made in vivo wholesale patch
flame recordings and walking flies
and here we're paying attention to all
three rotational axes of the spherical
treadmill
and we observed as many other people
have observed
that the sideways velocity of the fly
and the rotational velocity of the fly
tend to be fairly correlated that just
means that steering maneuvers
generally seem to involve concerted
sideways and rotational movements on the
fly
and it's sort of quasi-independent from
the fly's translational
velocity it's forward running
you'll notice i've marked an asterisk
three
sort of discrete steering maneuvers the
fly is making in the same direction
in the snippet of data and what you'll
see is that in a
simultaneous recording we made from the
a2 descending neuron
the atria descending neuron proceeds and
predicts each of these
steering maneuvers and i should say that
this neuron was recorded
on the side that corresponds the
direction the fly is steering in
for each of these three maneuvers so
prior to each ipsilateral steering
maneuver
the a2 cell is depolarized and its
firing rate increases
and if we make simultaneous recordings
from
the a2 neuron on the right and the left
side of the brain it turns out we can
quite accurately predict the fly
steering
so here i'm just showing you rotational
velocity at the top as a function of
time
and i'm showing you in this experiment
during the snippet
the simultaneously recorded copy of a2
on the right
and a2 on the left you'll see that a2 on
the right
tends to burst before rightward turns
and a2 on the left
tends to burst before leftward turns
and if we actually make a linear model
that incorporates
equal contributions from the two cells
we can see that
the model in black and the bottom is a
pretty good prediction of the fly's
rotational velocity in gray
interestingly these cells tend to be
somewhat anti-correlated during steering
but they become positively correlated
when the fly transitions from locomotion
to rest
you can see that happening right at the
end of this trace
in the epoch marked with the open
arrowhead
and the top trace both cells become
hyperpolarized and now they begin
become active in a more simultaneous
positively correlated manner
and so here i'm going to summarize a lot
of data with a cartoon
we found that steering neurons integrate
multiple sensory modalities
so we've found that a2 predicts odor
evoked ipsubversive turns
but a2 also predicts heat evoked
controversive turns
so just to explain what we did we
expressed channel rhodopsin in plural
sensory neurons
either in peripheral olfactory neurons
or in peripheral thermosensory neurons
and then we illuminated either the right
or left antenna independently
and we found that when we eliminated the
fly's left antenna
to drive activity in olfactory receptor
neurons on the left
the fly would typically make a leftward
turn and a2 would predict this
the left copy of a2 would burst
conversely when we illuminate the left
antenna
and channelrhodopsin was expressed in
peripheral thermosensors
the fly would typically turn to the
right and a2 would also
predict this that is the right copy of
a2 would burst
just before the turn and so this shows
several things it shows us that
a2 predicts odor evoked turns and
multiple sensory modalities
indicating that it is downstream from
multiple sensory modalities
it also shows us that a2 is not encoding
the side of the stimulus the side of the
body where the stimulus was present
rather it is encoding what is about to
happen
in the motor system i think a causal
contribution for a2
in these turns is supported by the fact
that a2 could predict
the trial to trial variability in the
magnitude
of the turns in responsibly sensory
stimuli
and more over in experiments that i'm
not going to have time to
show you we found that unilaterally
activating a2
was sufficient to bias the flies turning
in the ipsilateral direction
and we found that bilaterally silencing
a2
interfered with normal body and leg
movements
suggesting this cell again has a causal
role
in steering in addition to predicting
steering maneuvers
so next we ask is the compass
functionally connected to a2 neurons
to find this out we want the design
experiment where we could trigger a turn
by injecting a signal directly into the
compass system
so what we did here was to
move the bump of activity around by
stimulating
p-e-n-1 neurons with a chemogenetic
method
and this is a method actually pioneered
by gabby neyman's lab at rockefeller
what you need to know for the purposes
of this experiment is just that
when you stimulate pen1 neurons in this
manner
it causes the bump of activity to jump
to a new location
on the compass you can see this here in
several
example trials i'm showing you bump
position
as a function of time and at the moment
when you stimulate pen1 neurons
you can see that the bump jumps to a new
location
now the interesting thing is over time
over some seconds
the bump then tends to return to its
original location
and that's because during that time
period the fly performs a compensatory
steering maneuver in fact it tends to
perform a compensatory steering maneuver
that's just the right size to bring the
bump back
to its original location and as gabby
gabby's lab pointed out of this is
evidence that the bump position is
continuously compared with some
internal heading goal and when we induce
a mismatch
between the fly's perceived heading and
its internal heading goal
in essence when we fool the compass into
thinking that the fly has been pushed
off course
the fly will make a compensatory
steering maneuver to bring the bump
back to match its internal goal
um and that is what is causing
the bump to return that compensatory
steering maneuver
so we've got the ability now to trigger
steering maneuvers
by injecting a signal into the compass
so these are compass
driven steering maneuvers and what we
wanted to know
is does a2 also proceed and predict
these steering maneuvers
so together with imaging epg neurons
in chemogenetically stimulating pen1
neurons and monitoring the fly's
behavior we also made
simultaneously wholesale passionate
recordings from a2 neurons
and indeed what we found is that a2
firing rates
went up just before the fly's rotational
velocity
increased during the compensatory
steering maneuver
and that happened just before the epg
bump
returned to its initial position
what that argues then is that a2 neurons
are functionally downstream from the
compass system
and they participate in steering
maneuvers that are driven by
and guided by the compass system
so we found actually is that there's
only one cell type interposed between
the compass
and a2 and we found this out by
identifying a2 within
the full brain serial section em volume
that dobby box lab generated
when he was at janellian research campus
and then working backward we partially
reconstructed all of the inputs to a2
in that volume and we found that outputs
the compass system
were among those neurons and we fully
reconstructed those neurons
i'm just going to schematize the anatomy
of these neurons because it's kind of
interesting
here's a schematic of the epg compass
and here i'm showing you the heading map
that's formed in the protocerebral
bridge when epg
neuron axons terminate in the protociral
bridge
transferring the circular heading map
from the ellipsoid body
to the protocol bridge epg neurons make
direct connections
with this interposed cell type
which is represented here as a set of
lines each line connects
a synaptic input in the protocol bridge
denoted by a square with another
synaptic input and the fan
shape body denoted by a circle and
each of these neurons again represented
by a line terminates
onto a descending neuron either the
right copy of a2
or the left copy of a2 and so what we
think is that
these neurons translate an estimate of
the fly's current heading state
into a steering command in a manner that
depends on
the nature of their input at that moment
from the fan shaped body such that
changes in fan shaped body input
could essentially change the policy in
the fly brain
about how to steer given
a particular heading state and so we're
currently exploring that hypothesis
using computational modeling and
experiments
we also found in em reconstructions that
a2 receives direct input from a variety
of higher order
sensory brain regions visual brain
regions mechanosensory brain regions
olfactory thermosensory and auditory
brain regions
indicating that this cell type
is a node of integration for multiple
sensory modalities
compatible with our functional evidence
of course this is exciting for us
because it really
raises the possibility that we could
study integration between the compass
system
and these different sensory modalities
to summarize we identify descending
neurons whose activity is sufficient
to produce steering and whose activity
is necessary for normal body and leg
kinematics during steering
these descending neurons integrate
stimulus directed steering drives and
compass guides during drives
and these descending neurons are just
two synapses downstream
from compass neurons so to kind of zoom
out for a moment
we've sort of studied how
all the brain regions i've mentioned are
really embedded in
a set of parallel feedback loops
because keep in mind that whenever the
fly steers right or left
that feeds back to change the apparent
position of a visual cue
or the apparent direction of the wind or
the apparent
lateralization of an olfactory or
thermosensory or auditory cue
relative to the body and in this sense
the blue and arrow the brown arrow and
the black arrow form a kind of
direct feedback loop short feedback loop
for steering
but recall also that um there are
signals that are sent back
up to the compass system either
proprioceptive feedback from the lens
and or copies of motor commands possibly
motor commands from
a2 itself that
sort of move the compass bump even in
the dark
and when visual cues are present or as
we have seen
when the wind is blowing the direction
of the wind and the position of visual
cues
also provide constant feedback in the
compass system
and so that in this manner the compass
system forms a kind of a more
complicated longer outer feedback loop
that operates in parallel with the inner
feedback loop
that bypasses the compass system
and so in the future we're really
interested in studying how these
different feedback loops
are integrated how conflicts between
them
are adjudicated how the gain of each
component
is adjusted so it works properly with
the other components
and how they all work together to drive
seamless
fluid navigation in a complex
environment
so i want to close by i'm just
acknowledging and thanking our
nih united team collaborators and their
labs
and i want to give really sincere thanks
to the nih
brand initiative for funding this
ambitious multi-lab project thank you
all right well thank you so much
uh rachel for that really amazing talk
um it's fascinating to think about how
these different circuits network with
each other
um to guide behavior and you're really
getting down to brass taxier
and um it's it's wonderful to to
to see the complexity so elegantly
described and simplified for us so that
we can really truly understand it
i'm going to now ask some of the
questions that were in
submitted by attendees in the q a
session
the first one i think is really
interesting to think about um
and it is regards to
translation really can you comment on
how we might use the insights
we developed from the drosophila to
guide or help
understand what's happening in more
complex animals whether they be
other reptiles or mammals
that's a great question so i mean i
think
complex brains are just different from
simple brains and we shouldn't pretend
they're the same
but all complex organisms
and i would definitely say flies are a
complex organism
all complex organisms face a kind of a
common set of
problems to be solved in the world
and we share a lot of genes we share a
lot of evolutionary history
so i think it's fair to guess that
neural circuits
will be using some kind of common
strategies common problems
common strategies to address these
common problems and so for example the
compass neurons of course most people
know that they have a lot of homologies
with
head direction neurons in rodents
and primates and head direction neurons
are thought to be an input to
place cells and grid cells as well as
possibly being intermediate between
those spatial maps and motor commands
and i think we can learn a lot from
understanding how the compass system
might form a kind of a
backbone or framework for doing various
navigation guided tasks
and also understanding how it integrates
with non-compass driven
navigation i think a couple things are
going to be useful in helping us to kind
of generalize results from drosophila to
other organisms
one is the connectome the more we
understand about the drosophila
connective the more we can use it to
predict what we might see in more
complex connectives and then actually
make those comparisons
um and then second of all i think
computational models are going to be
important because computational models
allow us to kind of climb up the ladder
of abstraction
and take our data and step back and say
well
what are the kind of insights that might
come from our data
that we might be able to generalize
allow us to design
better experiments in other animals
while we're on the subject of the
connectome
talk about the importance uh the
influence of the em connectome
on your hypothesis you described how you
actually used it
to figure out what neurons to study next
are there any other
ways in which having a connectome really
helped you
from the perspective of understanding
this system
i think speaking personally uh the
connectome
in drosophila um has
like been one of the most exciting
things that's happened to me in my
scientific career
i should say that we don't exactly have
a finished connectome so we have the raw
data
for the connectome of a full
adult female brain that's the work of
dobby bach
we also have a machine segmented
machine assembled connect dome
for a part of the female brain and
that's the
new project that just came out of
janelia
i think in parallel various people are
working to augment those data sets and
we really need um something that
connects the brain to the spinal cord of
the fly that's critical here
but that said even though the data and
the analysis is still partial
it's been huge for us the three studies
that i talked about actually got started
before we had a lot of this connectomics
information
and so we're integrating information
into those projects kind of on the fly
which was
both stressful and really exciting i
think going
forward it's going to be very powerful
in allowing us to identify other
descending neurons involved in
navigation
in walking and then to work backwards
from them to
understand what their inputs are and how
their inputs are integrated and
recruited at different times
yes you did this all on the fly pun
intended
suppose um
the another questioner asks at the risk
of asking a naive question
which is always worth the risk from my
perspective to what extent would these
rules and circuits apply to flight
versus walking as measured by the
trackball do you observe that the
flies engaging their flight muscles or
wings in an interesting way when they're
engaging in these behaviors so there are
other ways to look at how this might be
occurring during flight yes i think
um durosafel are interesting um
because like many other insects they
actually have two ways of getting around
right there's the the um system for
controlling the legs the limbs
but also a parallel system for
controlling the wings
and flies don't walk and fly at the same
time
but it seems likely that some of
the apparatus for planning and executing
navigational strategies
might be common between those pathways
so
my collaborator michael dickinson in our
nih brain initiative funded consortium
has been really doing a lot of work to
identify
the components of the navigation
apparatus
that works during flight and also how
sort of
interesting and specific motor control
problems are solved
in flight and so kind of like the common
theme of our project is loops in the
nervous system and
it's interesting to think that the loops
that control navigation walking
are also working in parallel with work
loops that control navigation and flight
how these things
how conflicts between them are resolved
and how they're integrated is a really
fascinating question
excellent so more to come maybe when we
do know the whole full connectome of the
of the fly you can integrate those two
systems
um there were a number of questions
around plasticity
um and i'm going to try to merge them
into one
the plasticity experiment in particular
where you uh have cells that emerge with
two receptive fields seem really
fascinating to me
and to a few other of the questioners so
what does that remodeling of the
receptive field tell you about the
functional role of those
epg neurons during active navigation and
how is it compatible
with the potential of those cells to
develop through plasticity to receptive
fields
right so i think the question um that
you asked josh is a related to this
experiment where we created
a virtual reality environment with two
bright objects
um 180 degrees apart you can think of it
as like the tatooine experiment there
are two suns in the sky
they just are on opposite sides of the
sky so we designed that experiment
because
we thought that the flies had to be
confused by it
essentially visual motor experience had
to be perturbed it had to be a
big kick to the system in fact we did
see remodeling
what that experiment doesn't tell us is
why plasticine and remodeling is useful
because what we did is we took a
functioning compass and we basically
broke it
uh we created a period of several
minutes after the training experience
where the compass didn't function
properly
so you could say well why is that useful
um
we think that actually this plasticity
might be particularly useful
in allowing the fly to integrate um
different compass cues from different
sensory modalities
so for example i showed you in the
middle part of the talk that the compass
is informed by wind direction as well as
the direction of
like a prominent visual object such as
the sun
and so if either the visual r neurons or
the
mechanosensory r neurons made um plastic
connections onto epg neurons
you could see complicity processing
would allow
the system to relearn the angle between
the wind and the sun when that angle
change
abruptly say if the wind was steady and
then sort of shifted to a
different um as a methyl angle
excellent um this uh next question is
about
integration between two different kinds
of inputs is there synergy between
wind and olfactory inputs so that each
could inform the other or i guess both
could inform the compass system for
tracking olfactory plumes
so we don't um know whether olfactory
cues
affect the compass and if they do how
they might affect the compass
one interesting thing that reminds us
there's a lot to be discovered here is
that
there are lots of different r neurons
ring neurons whose functional properties
have not been characterized before
they're they're really a lot of like
orphan our neurons right
and some of these are neurons have
dendrites and brain regions that we just
don't know anything about
so it's possible they could be bringing
other kinds of
um like multimodal sensory cues to
the compass so for example in work in
big insects
insects bigger than drosophila it's well
known that the angle of polarized light
in the sky has a big impact on the
compass
that hasn't been shown so clearly in
drosophila it's pretty likely some our
neurons are devoted to that
whether there are neurons that um uh
encode
signals related to odors sort of um an
open question
our working model right now is that
a lot of the effects of odor on steering
either are altering the
gain of um sort of spatial guidance cues
coming from the compass or coming from
the visual scene more directly
or else insofar as voters are providing
guidance cues
potentially by stimulating the right and
the left nostrils you know antenna
asymmetrically that may be bypassing the
compass system
um and so may set up potentially sort of
a conflict or a tug of war between
these more direct pathways to the
steering control system and the compass
media pathways
okay i'm there's really a time just for
one or two questions left but i want to
before i ask the last question or two i
just want to let everybody know that
in one minute at 11 30 the next two
talks are starting so
i'll go feel free to leave at any time
to go back to the auditorium to pop into
those talks
uh and uh remember that there are
interactive things and lots of other
options to explore
throughout the the next day and a half
uh
so uh i'll get down to again a brass
tacks here from
a question from one of our attendees um
that
uh noticed that there appeared to be
step like
effects in the wind experiment in the
epg cells and
uh and this particular person thought
that they might have corresponded to a
period of two pi
over three and uh he's wondering if
that's uh consistent and if it's a
feature of the analysis of the neural
representation or the geometry of the
system that you're using
yeah certainly getting used to circular
statistics has been a learning curve for
everybody
now um almost everybody in my lab has
the matlab circular statistics toolbox
installed very useful
but that kind of step like discontinuity
is not a
systematic or consistent feature
of the wind direction tuning curves of
epg neurons
what we typically see is epg neurons
have wind direction
tuning curves that go a slope of about
one
meaning when the wind rotates all the
way around the fly
the compass bump moves all the way
around the circle
with on average a pretty smooth
relationship but there are these little
discontinuities that are idiosyncratic
across flies
and that may reflect this trade-off
between
um plasticity and stability in the
system so that
the fact that um our neuron inputs to
epg neurons
may well be plastic makes it impossible
for the compass to be
um always soft consistent and [ __ ]
perfectly just because
always those functional weights are
being would think um
influenced and updated based on sensory
motor
experiences so we're really interested
in knowing whether that's true in the
wind inputs of the compass as it seems
to be in the visual
inputs of the compass but one more
indication of plasticity in the system
is that the offset between the compass
and the
wind world is different than different
flies that's suggesting it can't be a
hardwired
feature of this system great well
thank you rachel for taking us from
these brass
tacks through to the high level
descriptions of
uh what is a really interesting and
compelling circuit
um and i uh and i'm sure others
can't help but uh understand how the
simplicity
of the system even i mean it's complex
and it's simple in the sense that it's
simpler than
than what we might be expecting in other
animals but it really
helps inform and set the stage for how
we can dissect these circuits in a
behaviorally relevant way
but that really gives us tremendous
power to control the system and to
understand it
to computationally describe it it's it's
really pioneering work
i really uh appreciated hearing from it
and i'm sure so did the many other folks
i'm gonna say goodbye for now and uh
and again welcome everybody to uh
experience
other portions of the virtual meeting um
and uh and to give us feedback along the
way
be sure to let us know what works and
what maybe doesn't work for this really
grand experiment of trying this virtual
meeting for the first time
anyway thank you all bye now